all right in this video we are going to
talk about the elements tab of Google
developer tools using the elements tab
you can do a lot with HTML and CSS
changing some other website while you're
in the browser it's pretty cool so I had
a camper suggest to me to work on this
page which is Ian McKellen's actual
official home page it could use some CSS
and HTML help we're really just gonna
mess around with it so one way to get to
the console or to the really just going
to mess around with it one way to open
up the developer tools especially when
you're looking in elements is to right
click and hit inspect element whatever
you right click that's the element that
it's gonna inspect so here on this left
side of cascading information it pulled
up exactly all the information that HTML
and over here it's all these style
elements that apply to it let's go ahead
and change that awesome picture of Sir
Ian McKellen to this picture of a cat in
a turkey costume so I'm just clicking
here in the SRC and I'm just gonna paste
my link from the other link and suddenly
we are looking at a cat on the home page
of McKellen com
additionally so say we go down here
let's make this color not be blue
anymore we're gonna click inspect
element and instead of changing over on
this left cascading side we're gonna
change in here and so you can see it
says background color if I double click
that lets do
AAA BBB which turns out to be this
lovely light purple color so suddenly
we've changed all this kind of stuff and
we can even change text so if I wanted
to say I'm continuing to right click and
hit inspect element here it says what's
new instead let's have it say three code
camp is thebomb.com there we go and now
free code camp is thebomb.com is what
that first little highlight above box
says so that's pretty cool
additionally
I'm going to move everything over to the
right hand side now there's this kind of
box over here that says margin border
padding that's a really quick and easy
way to edit those specific attributes of
whatever you're looking at
it says margin border padding that's a
really quick way to edit those
attributes within the browser again you
can't save any of this within the
browser without changing some some
settings let's inspect element of this
cat photo let's have it have a border of
ten pixels let's just see what happens
there
border ten margin let's try margin 100
on the top so here it was the top number
if I do it on the left hand side 100
it's there right hand side 100 bottom
100 so really all I'm doing it's editing
it in real-time which is super cool
padding is the same you can do this for
anything that you're looking at on the
web page you can edit it all here it is
important to remember that cascading as
far as what takes precedence so if
there's a class that has an attribute
that is applied that's still going to be
more important to the browser than if
you just apply it to all divs if there's
a div class of top box and that has a
certain color that's going to override
any other just general div things that's
the same as regular CSS those rules
still apply here so now finally we're
gonna erase all of our amazing efforts
here if we refresh everything goes back
to normal so that's the elements page
that fun playing around